so i mapped out this plan to um
do what was really in my heart that i
wanted to do which was do a lot more
writing
um kind of like leverage my knowledge a
lot more create like
information products books i started a
podcast i started a blog
i started a newsletter um and in 2009
i was voted as america's top personal
trainer
by the national strength conditioning
association and that kind of thrust me
in the limelight of like
traveling around all these conferences
giving talks from stages to personal
trainers about the fitness business and
you know i was kind of making a name for
myself there and so um
so from about 2010 onwards you know i i
started doing a lot more what i do now
which is
you know i coach and consult with people
from all over the world about you know
health and
performance and you know sleep gut you
name it and then i do a podcast
do a blog write books write articles
you know do some investing in the health
and fitness sector you could have
literally
turned every one of these chapters into
a book but you put them all in
one book which is like so ambitious
and so cool and just also that you know
says how much
you wanted to get that information out
there so what was it
when did biohacking like becam become a
word or a thing
do you really like when did biohacking
become a thing that you'd
seek and try and figure out and have we
actually always been doing it we just
gave it a name
yeah it is it's the latter we've always
been doing it but we gave it a name
i mean if you look at our ancestors and
this is interesting i was having a phone
conversation with somebody about this
yesterday
um because they said well i want to do
this and this and this but i don't want
to take
any supplements at all it's like you
know whatever they had you know low
vitamin d
and low red blood cell magnesium and
some issues with with the gut
but they're like you know i just want to
do this through you know food and
movement
which which is kind of laudable you know
want to take a natural approach yet
when you look at our ancestors you know
humankind for all of its existence and
the animal kingdom as well
has been relying upon you know plants
root
barks leaves teas tinctures powders oils
salves
you know blends all these things that we
get from nature
the emergence of say
modern encapsulation technology which
allows us
with a little bit of better living
through science to
do those same things and harness those
same herbs and plants and powders and
extracts etc but in a little bit more of
a
convenient manner doesn't mean that
something like supplementation is
unnatural it's something
that we've done for a long time uh you
know
and in the realm of of biohacking and i
would say
you know in some ways you know
supplementing with certain things can
certainly fall under the category of of
using certain hacks to
adjust your biology which is basically
what biohacking is
um to a certain extent we um
we do that with technology too right
like
you know since the 40s we've known that
you know
i'm just going to use a far out example
here like sunlight
on a man's balls can increase libido and
testosterone right so
i've been recommending that every day to
my boyfriend i'm like let's
just put some sun on your balls do some
perineum tanning
but now now we have all these these red
light technologies that joking aside you
know when
when a man uses you know like 10 to 20
minutes of like
uh you know a mix of of of different
red lights like infrared light you know
on his gonads you actually see an
increase in
testosterone and blood flow and so you
know that it's something our ancestors
were done with the sun and now we're
doing it
with red light panels and ultimately
for me the initial idea
that there are things that you can do
that go beyond just say like
exercise and nutrition to amplify muscle
growth or recovery or sleep or
gut health or anything else was
something i discovered when i was
bodybuilding
because i had a brief stint for a couple
of years
in college as a bodybuilder so i was
about 175 pounds in college
i got a dare from one of my friends
to sign up for a bodybuilding
competition that was like 11 months away
so i signed up for it and you know just
started
lifting like an animal and you know
downing these man in a can
chemical infused protein shakes like six
times a day and
you know showing up at the gym at 4 am
before my classes and you know downing a
bunch of
red line or whatever other mix of
pre-workouts happen to be at the gym and
you know getting my uh yeah they
they work i mean they're essentially uh
you know a mix of
you know ephedra and sildenafil you know
basically an
upper with something very much like
viagra for blood flow but you know they
they work they're uh fast track to a
heart attack at the gym
but they work um and so i uh
i i started bodybuilding you know just
lifting like an animal
so i put on about 45 pounds of muscle
and you know wound up competing uh 215
pounds
and about 3 body fat but along the way
of course via all these magazines and
old school online forums you know
you i started to delve into you know all
this bodybuilding lore and literature
and i think bodybuilders when it comes
to the physical culture aspects of
biohacking
were some of the original bio hackers as
far as like oh here's the
the pill you pop and here's what you
inject and here's the
here's the different you know creams and
powders and you know everything from
um you know peptides and sarms to
wrapping tourniquets around the muscle
to decrease
blood flow to increase results so a lot
a lot of stuff people are
are funny enough just now kind of like
making popular and discovering in the
past five years you know 20 years ago
bodybuilders doing this so so that was
kind of like even though i was a
poor college student and all i could
afford was like creatine
and tuna and protein shakes i still
you know paid attention to a lot of that
stuff and then um
you know in in the past
several years biohacking seems to have
just
exploded in terms of a term that is used
to describe a lot of things
that really i don't think are biohacking
right like i don't think say like
um you know let's say you know putting
butter
ghee or coconut oil into your coffee
or going for a walk barefoot in the
sunshine is
biohacking right that's just like
basically a
cooking and b walking outside in the
sunshine without your shoes on yeah it's
not biohacking
right but the original biohackers if you
actually look at
the history of biohacking they were
called grinders
right they called their body wet wear
and they would use
technology that they'd call hardware to
amplify
certain aspects of human function so
these would be like the type of people
who
install like a tiny magnet in the chest
that will vibrate
every time that you face true north or
small
magnetic implants in the ears that
enhance hearing
or you might find a you know a story
online about the guy who
injected chlorophyll into his eyeballs
for
night vision um or
another example would be kevin warwick
probably original so-called human cyborg
who
literally he and his wife uh installed
like magnetic implants in their fingers
to be able to
kind of like that movie minority report
be able to interact with screens and
technologies
and so that that i really think is like
the true original term of biohacking
literally like a computer hacker taking
apart a hard drive
and amping up the graphics software or
the graphics card
or um you know or defragging a computer
and make it run faster or whatever
you know these people are using like
technology to
literally implant things in the body or
remarkably
and quite significantly alter human
biology in a way that i think is is a
true
hack i think a lot of what we do now
that we call biohacking
even though of course the term has
umbrella to cover a lot of different
things
is really just like using smart living
and science to be healthier